bianca holmen is live this morning with
a look inside and
outside before all the cool people
arrive the coolest of them all is there
already bianca good morning
yes all the vip listers like john and
alex showing up this evening
but yeah we've uh i just want to kind of
send you where we are we actually are on
top of the employee parking deck
this is right uh next to sammy davis
junior and then also
in between las vegas boulevard but we're
on kind of the back side
of the resort and of course we've been
taking behind the scenes all morning
and we're going to talk now about the
pool the resorts world that has a five
acre pool complex with nine pools and
it's really set up for a party
atmosphere
there's also a more family-friendly pool
along with the vip pool that has an
infinity edge with
views of las vegas strip unfortunately
we weren't allowed to film that one for
you but
one cool note about the pool a lot of
trees were recovered from the old
star dust before it was imploded back in
2007 so they transferred
they transfer those trees to a nursery
and then they move them here for resorts
world
so work isn't done yet the day club and
nightclub won't open until
next week as several shows are planned
for fourth of july weekend
and then we've got work is also being
done on the 5000 seat theater that's
going to soon play host to celine dion
luke bryant katy perry
and carrie underwood and of course the
private party
is open tonight and of course lots of
people will be there you'll be able to
tour around
the casino and again just to kind of let
you know where that pool is it's right
there and then also there's the entrance
to the restaurant road the street eats
that we showed you yesterday and that
we've been showing you throughout the
morning
so amazing amazing property we're so
excited the north end of the strip
definitely has a gem
with this one back to you guys in the
studio it looks very cool bianca
it looks like there's still maybe a
little bit of work to do there's
construction on the on las vegas
boulevard out in front but inside looks
like it's all locked in
it looks gorgeous bianca and if you need
to know anything about the pool yes
bianca's got it all planned out for us
thank you so much